what's going on I've been I guess I've
been feeling like a lot of things during
this recently I've been feeling like
well I've been taking pretty good care
of myself you know I've been doing a
good bit of um outdoor action running
walking um you know I'll pretend like I
lost something right in my area or
something go look for it look for a
missing animal look for a you know like
oh my cousin's car got stolen
I'm we know we're looking for it if you
seen it people like nah nah nah but you
keep looking you know just anything to
kind of get out of the house you know
what else I've been rolling out my Bobby
and I know some people they say you get
on the foam roller if you've seen it
it's a it's like a pipe but it's made
out of foam it's like a foam piping
piece like a fat little foam pipe and
you lay your body on it and you just
ride your body back and forth on it I
mean if this thing could get pregnant it
would get pregnant and you just slide
your body your legs especially your
thighs here your buttocks here the area
between your nuts and your knees
whatever that is leg and you slide that
up and down this some foam roller and it
alleviates your tension I mean it you'll
see a damn ghost fly out of your ass
like if this thing will loosen the
muscle tension inside of you it really
does it just loosens it all up so I've
been doing that full-body like doing my
triceps on it my bicep like laying on in
just sheer agony just and just I mean
till it just hurts so much man till just
like and it's this big black pipe kind
of thing and it's like it just feels
like it's just
I mean just just taking my muscles
virginity you know just ruse just
terrorizing these [ __ ] really kind of
like if you ever seen an episode of that
black
pornography and it's women kind of
getting attacked by big large black you
know penises and penis and it has that
sort of ambiance to it just and just
rolling you're just I mean rolling my
chest is rolling everything out so I've
been doing that what else that's him and
not that there's not you know I went to
the park the other day I looked at some
dog people out there with a dogs um good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one